[Music]
at the moment it is nice to have things
that make us smile the video called
a surprise for children whose parents
are doing important jobs I'm Catherine
and this is Willie uh next to me
I agree should be very proud of her
they're doing an amazing job even though
they'd normally be closed now for the
Easter holidays Cass certain primary
academy in Burnley is still open for the
children of key workers William and Kate
wanted to thank all teachers across the
country who are currently going above
and beyond
all the parents who are key workers to
know that their children eyes you're
saying city from the normality is there
for them and they've got the structure
and they've got a safe place for them to
be so really really well done and sort
of you know it's not easy circumstances
thank you so much I think everyone's
just please Phil to help yeah good good
northern volunteering spirit going on
this is a really exciting thing to
happen at any time for any school but in
the situation that we're in with all the
you know the bad news stories we're
looking for any positives that we can
find and this was an absolutely positive
experience for everyone involved some of
the children's parents work at Burnley
hospital which is nearby but the school
is also providing emotional support for
any pupils who need it at this
unsettling time a virtual school visit
is a first for the couple like everyone
it seems they are trying to keep some
sense of normality
keep eating it we animals Sky News thank
you so much everybody